bonjour merci d'être avec mon direct sur
rt france alors est ce que ces nuits
d'émeutes sont la preuve que la paix est
fragile en irlande du nord
oui ce n'est pas très réjouissant c'est
certain et ça fait après deux nuits de
d'assurer qu'il y a eu de la violence
donc en fait le reportage était
l'excellent je trouvais mais la violence
est encore plus que sporadiques il a
quasiment continue tous les to les nuits
donc que tout et nuit donc certainement
inquiétant sur faut-il regarder ce qu'il
ya derrière ce sont comme votre
reportage de la signaler des jeunes
voient des très jeunes qui sont
impliqués dans dans ses actions
donc qu'est-ce que ça reflète vraiment
la la vie de sentiment de la population
en général on peut quand même en douter
il y à aussi il faut de savoir d
organisation doit yanis mais qu'ils ont
également un côté criminels qui se
livrent à des activités criminelles de
type mafieuse et qui peuvent donc
utiliser et qui d'ailleurs ont fait
l'objet d'une certaine rigueur accrue de
la part de la police
dernièrement donc ça c'est un problème
éthique qui n'a rien à voir avec le
pratiquent et certaines personnes
pensent que les les responsables des
groupes groupuscule loyalisme et
criminel en même temps fumantes la
violence donc la situation est quand
même assez obscur assez difficile à dire
mais c'est inquiétant c'est très
simplement
alors cette fois-ci apparemment ce
serait le break citant qui manifestement
a causé le début de ces troubles
pourquoi pour demont raisons qui sont
assez faciles à comprendre je pense
qu'en tant que de reportage
évoqué à juste titre de déplacement de
la frontière à des fins du commerce des
contrôles douaniers à du contrôle des
normes réglementaires de de la frontière
qui délimite le vent du nord de la
république terran vers la mer du nord
donc c'est comme si en france on crée un
une frontière à l'intérieur de
l'hexagone pays d'un côté vous avez
l'alsace et la corse
et de l'autre côté le reste de la france
combien de partis politiques en france
soutiendrait une telle solution
aucun je pense et il se serait
certainement contraire à la constitution
française intérieure qui prévoit que
françois république une et indivisible
donc certains c'est une situation
bizarre mais qui est le fruit d'un
compromis qui a été négocié entre le
boris johnson et le reste le premier
ministre irlandais et l'union européenne
[Musique]
pour permettre d'avancer vers le brésil
mais c'est vrai que cette un peu bancal
qu'une situation et met en tout cas des
indiens avec le brésil parce que ça crée
des problèmes pratiques selon lui le
commerce seront closes très pratique est
rendu plus difficile certains produits
ne passe pas la frontière ou risque de
ne pas passer la frontière parce que les
délais les coûts administratifs seraient
plus élevés et il y à côté symbolique
très importante il faut savoir que l'on
en ait rebondi d'un mouvement
nationalisme au sein de la république
mais également en irlande du nord
ce sont des gens qui estiment que ce
serait mieux que toute l'île irlandais
soient réunis sous l'égide la république
demande est cuit alors que de l'autre
côté les vindellois indices qui sont
très attachés au 1
attachement à la couronne donc ce
déclassement de frontières quand même ne
rit un peu d'espoir des nationalistes et
créer une véritable angoisse au sein des
des lois disent parce qu'ils se disent
c'est absolument pas normal c'est même
franchement aberrants et qu'est ce que
ça nous qu'est-ce que ça va nous
apporter de à l'avenir vers quoi allons
nous donc il est quand même une
institution compliqué et angoissant qui
est en jeu thomson merci à vous d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes vice-président du parti
conservateur britannique en france merci